我们第一个问题就是说可能想了解一下就是我们今天的三位大家就你现在是在做什么做什么工作然后能简单介绍一下自己的一个工作经历吗呃首先是我们的呃范老师吧好的谢谢谢谢主持人嗯我大概是在2012年左右才出来那个做那个就是id这个行业的然后那个
在此之前我的目标是去做科学研究所以后面我对我觉得ID还是一个很不错的行业我就来做ID最快乐然后差不多我们出来做的话我们一开始在训练那边我们是从技术研发那边开始做起来然后我们后面大概做体验后面就也中间也跑去做下一代技术做PASS平台还有训练什么的都做过了
然後我現在是在CSDN這邊我們是做AI用AI技術來挖掘海量的數據然後就是我們還是做的目的還是幫助技術人去幫助技術人在協定上面學習成長然後以及創作內容或者就是或者如果你有很好的技術你可以在這裡面去幫助那些其他的
正在成長過程的技術所以我們在先時間這邊也做AI然後我們也做學習產品包括我們也做一些技能數相關的事情就是我大概工作是這樣的一個過程總的來說是一個標準的做技術路線的一個方式對我感覺就是像范老師你其實做的這個方向應該都是就非常典型的程序員的成長之路而且是那種非常技術流派的程序員對不對
就是因为你本身从事这个像你说的这个ai的领域本身应该也是现在目前呃就是从从这个技术领域来讲也是一个非常呃怎么的说那就是非常需要一些技术攻击的一个方向对他呃做ai技术运源国内的话做ai的话还是有两类一类是做底层那个技术困甲的像百度啊或者就是one floor这些公司那呃我们的话在我们这边的话偏做运源
但是偏运的话你也是需要就是说你得理解那个AI相关的技术一定的数学功底然后有有那个稍微支撑一点的那个变成变成的方向的方面的经验因为实际上我们做系统的时候很多时候发现他很多问题的解决他不不但那是算法问题他还是需要你理解理解你的数据理解你的业务甚至理解你产品和运营就结合起来去做的所以就是
就這個方向的話就是如果一個有至於純是這個方向的做技術的那就是他可以就是一步一步的就從他一步一步積累嘛然後AI技術的話也是差不多也是過去幾年比較活熱的嘛但是任何一個技術他一般會經過一段時間比較活熱的時間之後呢他會進入一個就說那個他如果跨越過那個中間那個紅鍋的話就會進入一個黃金發展期嘛那差不多下
接下来十年左右是会是AI技术在很多领域不断渗透和运源的一个时代所以就是它是一个编程方式的转型就是从头那个从头做开发的可能就前端后端嘛然后这方布斯后端的话后面又演化出演化出方布斯技术啊服务啊这这这这这块嘛不是AI技术AI技术来做的话会是下一代编程方式的一个变化很多行业都会被渗透的对明白明白非常感谢
好的 然后另外是我们的红铭老师红铭老师简单介绍一下吧好 大家好其实我每次交流之前是非常喜欢介绍自己的大概经历了因为介绍经历的一个过程本身就是一个相互认识然后相互找共同点的一个过程吧那我的工作经历其实是很简单的就是说是2010年毕业之后在百度做了两年多的销售
然后呢就是因为其实从毕业的时候一直都比较喜欢写作的一件事就写一些什么大小豆腐块的文章啊然后也就在毕业前后的时候在这个从这个百度毕业前后呃在一家网站的主编看到的文章说你要不要加入我们这个媒体啊就是一家科技媒体叫塑图网呃然后在这个塑图网里面做了四年在三个城市做了四年然后
一直在做這個和內容相關的這個編輯啊然後或者一些採編一些主編還有一些在團隊管理的工作那個然後呢就是說從這個17年開始就一直在自己自己創業做這個自媒體那另外就是其實我對我的自媒體的一個理解一個定位就是說我是想把它當做一個記錄啊或者說科技這個領域還有這個商業領域的一個
小冊子是吧如果說司馬遷寫的是整個中國的這個華夏的這個歷史的話那我就是寫這個科技這個商業領域的一個自己的觀點一個小冊子如果能記錄或者說甚至推動這個科技互聯網行業向前發展的話那就是一些很開心很值得欣慰的事情那同樣就是說比如最近我
我們現在都在講這個什麼阿里和騰訊一直之前是相互屏蔽的嘛然後最近開始要講一個互通吧那其實呢我早在這個2019年3月份就開始呼籲我說這個阿里和騰訊你們不能這樣相互屏蔽的然後太降低網友的這個體驗了你們有必要互通然後就是這不是這一兩年就開始去國家開始推動這個事了吧另外呢就比如說還有一些這個
最近这两年国家开始治理这个弹窗广告和开屏广告那我早在2018年的时候我就开始呼吁中国所有的APP都应该取消开屏广告当然这个前因后果或者说原因什么的我就不在这里解释了太长了就可能这就是光这个解释都得半个小时对另外就比如说这个共享充电宝啊然后在2012年4月的时候我可能有人关注到它的最高的价格涨到了10块钱一个小时
然后当时我就写文章说我说你这个操作的话你违背了这个共享的精神然后一定不会太长久果然到了8月份然后就国家就开始约谈这个主流的共享充电宝企业然后逼着他们要求他们把价格降到了两到三块钱左右也就是10块钱的几乎就不存在了或者一定不一定不存在如果你看到谁的10块钱你举报的肯定是肯定是维反规定的
所以說其實就是整體我再關注這個科技互聯網這些事情然後也發表一些自己的看法然後試著然後去推動這個行業往前去走當然我前面說的那幾個可能不是因為我才會有這樣的動作但是只能說是我在這個事情發生之前掌握出了自己的一些觀點相信對這些事情的發展提到一點點推動的作用對 謝謝大家好 非常感謝
ok 好 那我们再看我们下我们最后另外最后一个嘉宾就是理事长这边Hello 大家好 我叫程徐源说日本微博叫李正东抖音叫做程徐源说日本其他平台也是叫程徐源说日本先说一下我现在在做什么首先最近我比较感兴趣的是做这个抖音和自媒体但实际上我也是开公司的然后我公司在日本开了八年多快九年了我们主要是给牙虎包括做一些app
还有软银SoftBank还有Docomo其他日本超级流大手来承接他们的APP说简单一点就是外包在国内叫外包是吧反正就是他们做不了的我们能做就是我的公司正在做的业务然后下面是介绍一下自己的工作经历我这些工作经历可能跟咱们打卡还有咱们直播间的可能小伙伴们不能比
首先我09年毕业的时候吧那个时候正好是08、09年进入危机我那时候就工资就只有两千块钱就从最底层的渣号程序员干起来挺苦逼的后来干了一年跳槽我就想我不能拿两千块钱了跳槽拿到了五千块钱然后混到了一个小离点的级别是进了进军的七路人员员但后来呢从七路人员员有点被这个排挤欺负啊就是
青岛拍戏了 因为我是山东青岛人 被排挤欺负后来想了想 这咋办啊 这个在国内做成全安公司稍微有点手啊 我想我买不起房买不起车啊 这个时候正好听到公司有一哥们啊就是听牛逼说他以前在日本工作的时候能拿四十万日圆的这个月薪后来我就想办法 学了学日语来到了日本
反正一直现在就是在日本工作最近我的兴趣是做抖音还有持续的管理公司对我说明白明白确实李室安这边也是一条非常就是也是另外一条完全不同的路啊就虽然可能确实原来也是做成室安的可能跟范老师一样当然可能就是走上了另外一条路我觉得这个其实也是也是一部分同学我觉得是可以参考的吧嗯
OK 那我们这个因为时间关系我们这个话就到这然后我们进入下一个话题这个话题可能就是更贴相于刚才的就是范老师和和那个李社长这边对然后可能因为红冰老师吧他其实不是这个行业的嘛但是我觉得他可能一会能补充一些他自己对这个东西的看法那我们就先把时间交给范老师就是你现在比如说正在构想的和正在实现的技术人工做之路
近期和远期有没有什么样的规划好 感谢我这边像我们那个做技术的话其实我做技术的话可能从事这个行业的时候就跟很多人不大一样我就是去观察和学习这个行业的那个规律嘛像我会那个我在那个在边观做边边边观做的时候我就会学习很多就是
正规的就是理论就是先笼件工程的一些理论嘛然后就是并且在实际工作中去验证就是那些想法很多想法他很多理论他诸里面谈的规律他跟现实的那个企业里面的运作的方式或者程序院那个发展的那个呃程序院发展他有几种路径嘛最终是呃个人个人技术的那个成长嘛然后第二种是他跟在企业里面他需要跟人协作那他就是
跟兩個人這些協作的一些方式方法或者這樣的一些方式再往下的話就是你要在一個團隊裡面合作
那就是你會去理解說個人技術成長的規律那跟人絕對工作的那個或者變成的相關的那個呃呃整個是成立有效的整個才是那個更好的方式然後再往下就是說在同隊裡面協作嘛那你做一個同隊的一個棒子呃一個成員或者你做一個同隊的leader或者就是他在不同的位置的話他分別要做哪些哪些事情那這些的話就是說呃他比較虛但是就是
但是也有很多前辈写了很多书先我们先时间的副总裁就是周星老师他有写一本书叫《构建自法》这本书的话他里面也就会比较系统的介绍这方面的就是我也他也在很多学校里面也是作为教材实验的我也是在编工作的过程中编去结合那些理论去验证你逐渐会发现说很多规律很多事情他都是有规律的
那就是我们写程序程序人其实很理性的就是如果你发现说这个规律它确实是在模式如果你在模式条件它连起作用了那你在工作过程中的话你可以去规览和总结出来然后反复的去迭代吗就是说这是一个方面就是方式跟方法上面的然后另外一方面就是就是那个就是回到回到程序人这个行业的话就是做一个程序人那他核心的核心的核心的
技術是他那个竞争力的核心之一嘛那就是呃我自己的话呢我从那个底层那个我在出来工作的时候我已经是在学校里面是计算数学博士毕业的然后那个我出来呃做编程的话那编程的话我们从西西在家还有那个呃
路啊还有那个什么后面加瓦啊还有那个嗯notages或者就是在后面luster啊还有piston就是不同语言不同编程语言不同技术展他会做不他有不同行业的应员因为他每个语言的背后代表不同的那个技术平台嘛写习加加他是底层大规模系统开发的那些luster的话近一两年的话是做区客连开发相关的项目是比较火火爆的那如果你是做ai的话那你肯定还是会用piston比较多那对于个人来说的话
基本上如果你是干毕业的或者是你工作的几年都没关系但是基本上一个核心的点就是你做一个一个时间段内作为某个技术就要把那个技术核心的项目做的作为寸心性的项目然后在里面学到真正的本事那你不动的累积的话你就可以建立一条正向反馈的路径那近期和远期
其实我个人那个就是中组的方向两个方向一个就是用技术来那个刚才说的就是理解技术你掌握技术然后用技术来创造产品然后再往下的话就是理解那个龙剑工程的开发的规律然后你不动的去理解就是研发产品可以用这些的东西那在这是技术这方面的另外一方面就是另外一个方向是教育这个方向
就我认为说那个技术可以改变世界是其中之一嘛另外一个方向就是很多时候我们很多在往下的很多说是人的问题那就是在如何对技术人来说就是承担过程度的话如何去为技术人提供更好的学习或者教育类的产品也是非常也是我关注的一个方向其OK谢谢他好的好的谢谢潘老师我觉得潘老师这边的话确实是
从很好几个层面就是讲到了关于说近期和远期的一些规划那理事上这边呢对因为对你也是另外一种路线嘛就我不知道你现在还是不是有在做一些技术的东西或者说你这边是怎么去看的这个事情的哦我先跟大家分享一下就是我的这个工作之路成长路线好不好OK可以可以没问题
就比如说其实我在国内的时候啊我是大概工作了三年多是做到了这个小Leader级别是带人嘛然后那个时候我就比较注重这个情商和给人沟通的这个培养因为我们程序员嘛咱说句实话啊有好多人就是摄孔摄孔就是他不善于跟上司交流不善于跟同体的人也不善于跟他的手下交流所以可能就有些人就只想走技术大牛这个路线
有可能就导致你这个上线就会怎么说呢上线有的人就不可能太高你比如说范老师是博士毕业但是我们几个人能干到博士能学到博士然后再去研究一些比较厉害的东西呢没办法什么我还是就是我作为一个普通程序首先大家心里有锻炼一下自己的情商哪怕是给你的亲女朋友家属锻炼一下跟朋友锻炼一下这个情商啊沟通的
这个技巧稍微大家要注意一下我想我在日本这么多年他们竟然说我是这边成员的情商天花板就说明了我们情人这个情商有多低这个情商有多低这真是没办法的事后来我当了leader以后啊我再发现这个跟夏说沟通好不过去教育知道人啊有他的好处
我后来来日本以后大概是在日本的公司包括日本的游戏公司外呆过日本的大手公司外呆过这个以后有时间跟大家分享是一年左右我就跳出来成立自己的公司为什么呢因为日本它这边的互联网比国内落后大概五到十年左右这是实话你们如果想要解释的话
我發現日本人的工作效率也很低特別是他們技術程序員跟我們國內的這個技術人員有太大的比較大的差距我們當時就說說在國內工作一年底的上在日本工作三年這個技術成長然後後來我就把我在國內工作那些小夥伴都召喚來日本然後成立了我的第一個小團隊在那個時候呢我們是只有人還沒有什麼太大的項目
就后来我就发现了日本一个比较缺的一个领域我一直坚信的是选择大于努力我们成员真的是选择大于努力方老师之前说过一句话叫做先选赛道是吧 方老师对 方向也是很重要但是我各的那位方向不说一下就是方向两个方向一个是
一種就是說那個選擇短期內快速的方向比如說一些風口的時期啊另外一種方式就是說但是那些那個方式有的時候會可以不可求然後另外一種方式就是說如果你自己認定的就是說那個長期這個方向是有價值的那你其實也可以選擇下去因為他你就按照自己的方向走吧你就不會因為風吹嘲斷就出現一些大的問題就是我覺得我對方向的理解是
两种就一种是机会方向一种是那个长期来看你自己觉得你认定这个方向确实就是你的赛你自己先走了那你就往下走也没有太大关系对对我本人当时的想法是吧我就选定了一个这个赛道然后我就长期深耕下去也的确是当时我选的是这个ROS赛道因为日本这边的这个移动开发的确是烂的一批啊ROS这边几乎没有什么人
后来我们就想做OS然后就后来机会就真的来了通过这个包括野村啊包括KDDI这些大使坊他们那个时候根本就不会做OS混合APP和这个TNML5前段一些比较复杂的技术后来我们就承接了一个KDDI的就是他们你们现在如果在日本有人的话你们去那个日本的KDDI营业厅啊就是AU Shop他们里面那个iPad上的APP还是我当年我们小团队做的
就我们大概就五六个人就做了就没东西啊所以大概就从那个时候开始公司就起来了我们几个人的收入也都长上去了真的是选择大于努力有的时候你看这个短期的比如说有的人跟我说拍摄好厉害我要学拍摄你说不是这么个事你得先选对着赛道先确定了这个赛道将来你可以挣得到钱可以在这个行业持续五到十年左右然后你再去努力
近期的利益永远比过远期的给你带来的收益我觉得就是凡是只看眼前利益的人基本上在我们成全这个行业吧不是很占优势嗯包括选公司也是包括选技术路线也是比如说有的人非要说这个今天购物业流行了我也需要去做购物业不是这个意思你得先去看购物业它这个发展历程啊包括它在美国的发展前景你看看
它这个发源地怎么样然后你再来决定你国内想不想干之类的大家一定要想清楚这个问题凡是任何一个开发语言和任何一个技术路线包括你的这个将来成长都是怎么着都要深耕而且我相信每个人的能力都是有瓶颈的大家遇到瓶颈的时候一定要再好好想一想再怎么突破再把这个赛道自己的选择再重新定位一下谢谢
这个问题我就要分享一角度OK我简单的理解一下就是理事上讲这两点第一个点就是说可能除了说一些硬实力吧就技术能力可能一些比如说像沟通啊情商这样的一些软实力同样也是很重要的对不对这个是我觉得理事上的第一个观点第二个观点其实就可能跟范老师刚才之前的那个观点不谋而合啊就是可能要选择一个相对来说就是自己能够就怎么说是能坚持的一个方向就是
可能在這個上面上去長期的去努力可能能拿到自己一個更好的一個收穫我不知道這些對不對非常對好的好的然後這塊那個弘明老師這邊有沒有什麼想要補充的補充的不多但我就一直有一個觀點就是說就是說可能在科技行業的這個早期的時候呢就是說像馬雲啊這種比較能說的
後來像馬哈藤這種產品對產品比較執著的人 專注的人還有機會但是到了現在這個階段我覺得就是說特別是等到這個區塊鏈時代以來 到來以後就真正懂技術的人就是因為那個叫什麼Called is Law是兩層意思嘛 是吧一個是規則 一個是法律就是說這個時候就是懂技術的人真正的是
具备了占到前台然后可以去掌控一切的这种节奏你看现在其实整个区块链是这个行业它没有太深的技术水平就是一个把各种技术的一个整合然后形成一个非常完整的一个新的一个世界对 我觉得现在在那样一个世界里面对我们技术人是非常友好的你可能不会像马云那么天花乐队讲天花乐队
同样你通过代码也是可以实现自己的一些的一个空间的这一点你理解我明白就是从鸿鸣老师讲说其实现在这个时代可能恰恰是技术人有机会的一个时代对更有机会的一个时代在早期的时候你得会演讲会融资会做品牌现在其实很多时候做代码也更关键了变得对我觉得这块比如说李社长和范老师没有这样的一个感受比如说
可以吃反对意见可以没问题我们没问题因为我们现在是圆桌嘛就我国内的情况我也的确不太了解是吧但是在日本这边来看吧当就怎么说呢我没有这么一个说法当你想在日本突破600万年收的时候你就得有一个怎么说会communicationcommunication这个也比较重要当你想突破一千万两千万年收的时候你就必须要会
去把別人說服了比如說他們有很多在日本做演講像雅虎那些大卡什麼的他們如果只會寫代碼只專注於代碼不懂得分享的話他會被公司淘汰他們公司到達比如說年收一千萬了年收一千五百萬他們必須要求你會分享懂得分享逼得你站上講台去分享甚至說讓你把非常難的東西給變成說人話
真的现在日本流行的是这个趋势特别是他们年数比较高的一波人好的我觉得这个话题可能我们聊的有点分散了对就是有一点发散了因为我们在讲刚讲的是一个工作之路对吧所以可能我们这个话题先暂时先跳过对但我其实理解可能还是说确实是在不同的一个社会发展情况就是刚才那个理事院讲到就是其实日本现在其实可能比国内陆喝四五年嘛可能确实是
就是还没到那样的一个或者说是没到那样一个阶段对所以我觉得我们可以先跳过这个话题可以吧OK我们继续讨论下一个话题OK而且我们讲的那个点就是今天跟我们这个主题相关的就是有被就是被毕业过吗或者有就是不顺利的事情当时是什么原因是如何走出这种不好的一个心理状况我觉得这个可能对于直播间的有一些同学可能会有一些参考的价值
这个要不李社长来吧因为我觉得之前也看过你的那个抖音上面其实也看你讲过一些之前的事情对感谢那些曾经欺负过我的人因为没有他们欺负我帮我这个这个硬逼出公司的话硬逼出原来那些软件公司的话可能我就不会这么走来到日本开句玩笑话说可能也就不会这么走买上房子开上了我的小法小法拉这样不是被拆了
虽然不是北裁员 但当时是什么一种状况其实是很惨就是有一个别的省会出身的这么一个 他不是山东省出身的一个部长然后在我们公司是直接空降空降过来以后呢我们原来青岛的这个被称为三差级啊就是我是Leader然后我上面是一个部长 部长上面是一个事业部长我们三个
當時是要被派到青島去成立青島分工司然後要被重用的直接就給我們升職加薪然後讓我們組建了很多青島出身的這個記錄者團隊包括還帶走還能帶走僅那些股幹人才但是當這個部長來了以後他先把事業部長給收拾走了就找各種藉口各種吐槽各種爽音招事業部長走了以後他又開始搞這個部長青島這個部長
听到部长搞完以后他就开始搞我了然后你说我一个利贷我一个利贷我底下就带着这么四五个人他连我都搞就不给任何一个我们这个听到分公司的人活路我当时被逼的实在没办法我跟大家说一下我在工作中有多么努力一周一共七天我恨不得出行八天什么九九六什么没有家没有宿舍就这样的往那使劲干
就不混到你这个人来赶我们走我们都不走当时真的是这个一个状况那时候是10年11年左右吧幸亏有这个部长欺负我们这个帮我逼走了逼走了以后我是想了想国内其他公司可能会不会遇到这种情况因为反正也是想来日本就提前就想办法来了当时是13年5月份来的其实来之前吧
我是就是對自己已經就是沒有太大的信心了因為遇到這種事情以後人真的會很低落這個情緒也會很低落然後都會懷疑自己因為我之前寫在馬題上去以後他就開始各種指責各種找查剛開始我覺得你這說的啥你懂不懂在買我覺得是他說的錯最後他就把你逼到一種什麼地步連鑄事這個格式什麼他都要給你指責
我就想你你現在給我開玩笑嘛你為什麼你要這麼來搞我真的是人的那個精神壓力承受度是有限的被搞的真的挺慘的我相信特別是牽扯到派系鬥爭牽扯到部門鬥爭權力鬥爭的可能真的有人會特別難受而且我當時就是家裡的狀況也不太好啊我爸當時肺癌晚期還得
哪怕是1000块钱工资对我来说都是很有用的忽然就被排挤当时就想自己离职还是不离职最后没办法还是想了想还是白白了这5000块钱工资的价格加班费可能要到8000块钱嘛对我来说都是特别重要的就在这种状况下不得不离开了当时不想离开的公司来到了日本背景离乡
包括来到日本以后不是像大家想象中那么顺利我刚来的时候跟我讲的那个公司说来以后有人接怎么做这个状况完全不一样一下飞机就是漂泊大雨然后也没人来接到宿舍以后在国内我住的是那种上下床的我不知道现在哪种就是上下床的那种宿舍在北京的时候当时就是出差的时候大家那上下床一个
小房间里在北京知春里我还记得是一个小房间里知春里我也去过知春里我也去过那个地方挺挺破的很破的是吧一个公寓里住了25个人包括房东所有人都是男女程序员其他的就这种环境里大家互相鼓励互相聊天拿着苦逼的工资挤着这个地铁
然后下了地铁以后赶紧吃一个鸡蛋惯饼往往思考那就是这么出来的我来日本以后状况也没有太好但是唯一的信念就是要挣钱要坚持坚持到发工资坚持到给家里寄钱真的是一点点坚持下来的难的时候想想家人就是真的是挺挺有用的我觉得一切的努力都是为了家人的幸福
能多挣一份感受一份钱谢谢对李社长在讲这个故事他可能讲的时候其实他现在已经像是在讲在讲一件别人的事情一样但其实我知道比如说包括直播间的同学包括像我自己本身其实也都经历过一些比如说职业上不愉快的时候但这种事情其实在你自己身上的时候你在那个环境里面其实还是你其实很难受的就
本管是大事小事但我觉得像理事上其他的经验事情可能都不算是小事都是很大的事情但他今天可以说是可能像讲别人的故事一样讲出来但是他那个时候那种状态我是能理解的对所以也确实是不容易包括我为什么会想请他来做我们今天的嘉宾也是因为确实看到他的一些故事觉得还是说实话挺立志的从那个时候到现在就是肯定过程中付出了很多然后也经历过很多辛苦对
但我觉得这可能也就是程旋这个群体比较怎么说的其实比较比较扛造扛造吧我觉得ok然后那另外两位那个嘉宾有没有什么想要就是补充的我谈一下吧我谈一谈感觉是刚才啊行你先我放哪是先我放哪是下吧
我非常认同那个刚才那个李社长说的一句话我觉得我就参加这个主播我记住的就是男的时候先想加来我觉得这个对所有人都是事员的就是无论你是不是干程序员但是程序员情绪也很也确实很事员吧就是其实做程序员一般都是比较纯粹的就是大部分人都是比较纯粹的就是或者就是或者即使你不是程序员从事ID这个行业大部分人是比较纯粹但是难免就是说你在资产上有的时候会遇到一些
困难那可能是各种原因都有可能那像刚才李涉然说的是一种例子嘛那那有的时候可能还有一些另外的例子有的时候现比如说现我们今天这个主题嘛就说那个呃现这今年可能会有一些那个分炒嘛那可能有可能你可能呃经历经历过这个事情那可能有不同的原因嘛有的时候可能是因为呃公司调整的原因啊或者有的时候是因为
一些你可能就是績效的原因那可能就是都有可能就是了那我我我個人覺得就是說那個就是無論是什麼原因但是他總是會過去的那就是我們如果發生了那裡就往前看就是往前走就是現理社上有的時候就是說一到危機他也是一個轉機
当然就是事后这是事后来看的但是在过程中的话就是我觉得就是做好往前看然后就是把自己能做的去做好嘛因为就是这个我们人类生就是关注值一段时间嘛那在过程中可能会遇到各种各样的事情就是对好就是我就简单谈一下这个观点对好的谢谢范老师刚才宏敏老师应该也有想想说的就是
如果说是被公司毕业我上班那几年呢就是说其实就是说2012到这个2018年之前16年然后那会其实整个互联网还是住在一个比较积极向上的一个发展的通道中所以说其实被毕业这种事呢就并没有那么多但是呢就是说我当时看到比较多的就是说
特别是在舆论层面我们看到有关30岁或者35岁的这种职场危机或者职场焦虑的这种说法因为我接触到很多人这个年龄的人开始有这种状态很多公司 特别是相对大的公司如果你到了35岁你还是一个一线员工的话然后没有成为管理层没有带团队那么这种人其实一般
公司的高層也好或者是人力資源也好就在管理這個公司的人力資源的時候就會發現這個人一般都不太想要了那一般就是說他在這個年齡而且這是公司對他的態度然後從他本人來講也有很大的焦慮他在這個年齡其實說一般都是上有老下有小要麼即便是單身也是那種大靈單身然後也可能就是
不再结婚生子了是吧那可能要是为下半生的这个养老啊或者说是等等的一些事业整种诸多问题产生非常焦虑的状态那其实对于这个问题呢我个人的看法就是说我不是特别认可或者相信说这个35岁或者30岁这个职场危机职场焦虑这么一个说法的更多的事就是说嗯如果就像说一个人你到了30岁或者35岁你还在一线
也就是基本上你工作了快10年了吧你还在一线员工那说明确实说你到了一个该转型的阶段或者年龄了只能说不同的人在不同的时期需要用这个不同的方法去做对应的事情吧我觉得到了30岁或者35岁这个职场这个危机交有你有职场危机有职场焦虑这种人其实应该考虑的是你现在做的事情是不是自己感兴趣的
如果你真正感興趣的事情就是說你可能就不會覺得特別焦慮如果說你只是為了說想通過這個工作掙錢或者說只是想有點事幹是吧那怎麼說呢你大半輩子還沒有學會怎麼樣遵從自己的內心選擇就是還不敢去大膽的去選擇自己喜歡的
甚至说是没有找到自己喜欢的事情我觉得这个应该是一个比较悲哀的事情吧啊我是谈一下这个35岁职场焦虑的一个事情啊谢谢OK哎那个我想问一下你社长你在在日本有有这样的一些焦虑吗就是这个现在就存在的吗生活不比较慢一些
现在机会说一下包括在我之前老有人问我说日本也有35岁被裁员被毕业这些事都愣着了我当时都不太了解我说你在说什么我说日本IT人才缺口150万日本学理工客人这么少日本就是互联网落后就是因为这边没有开发人才没有一线基本人才大家都不想在前线写代码就是这日本人的想法所以导致日本非常落后我说他们就是一线人才的工资
捧得特别高待遇特别好就是能写在码的人每一个公司把技术大佬包括我们公司包括亚虎包什么都是把那些真正的技术大佬捧得高高的捧在手心里恨不得话的那种感觉就哪怕什么都不干什么出去出国旅游都不敢让他跳槽什么的这对日本来说是不太可思议的一件事情日本这边好多技术大纽约技术中间深实的年龄其实是55岁
那你去日本公司你看他们那些55岁人写的马屁这啪啦简直比那些30来岁人还要牛他们这边如果成技术路线的话你能一直干退休真的就是他恨不得你一直干技术路线因为太多的人就无愿意在一线做这个技术研究技术比如说
這個OBS來說以前是Objective C後來換成Swift的那如果沒有人去帶領這個Swift公平那些領導的張嘴說啊Swift出來換一下那肯定不行必須得有大量的人去實驗去做產品然後不斷的迭代不斷的反饋他們才會有這麼一個進步咱們國內真的就是因為人才過剩灌的這些互聯網公司出來這些謀辯你換日本這邊簡直就是搶人才
就是包括现在日本那些剧头像新的 英帝的什么我去那一出手那直接就是一千一千二就是各种大家可能想象的那种福利地原来日本这种公司为了把员工留处甚至每个月都会举办什么你像拉尼特会举办那个家庭的地就是Family Day让小孩去他们公司了解他们公司的文化甚至想问他们你想不想做像你爸一样的工作呀
包括俠虎 オープンデイ 给小学生初中生甚至高中生去参观他们的公司跟他们的一些技术员去交流跟他们你看我们在做这个工作在做这个APP让他们去了解他们公司的文化产品一系列的社会的公益活动目的是什么?都是为了培养程序员甚至让程序员的这些家人了解程序员的工作来理解他们应该一样
當然其他國內的和歐美的我就不太了解我就分享一下日本之間的這個套口對我插題外話我記得那個李事讓你這邊其實一直在招聘的對不對我看你微博上對我們招聘主力啊其實還不是在日本我以前在日本圖的那些招聘的錢啊真的是招不來什麼
好的这个技术人才后来我就给路线微博照片没想到在微博照片就火了这花花花好多技术人才啊就是我在微博还有这个github上招来的嗯哎不错就我觉得就是直播间如果有同学可能想想去就是如果说想去日本什么之类的其实可以考虑一下李设然这边因为我之前记得李设然这边好像是会提供全程的那种类似接待的服务对不对会把你就是去了之后我全程接接到公司之类的
那肯定的,包括租房子,包括这是应该做的就是不光是我,包括其他的公司我觉得他们都会这么做的当然又有正规的公司,正规的公司,什么阶级啊,阶碗里有给租设施啊,提前弄好这些东西都会去做的OK,明白说到这里,我觉得如果在直播间同学的话也可以还是扫一下我们的那个交流群的二位马后面的话我们会把三位嘉宾都请到这个交流群里面就如果比如说对于李车远这边工作感兴趣同学可以在那个我们德不幸群直接联系一下
OK 这个是可以的吧 李水亮OK 等一下这本来我们就没事给大家提供一些经验 毕竟十几年OK 行 感谢 感谢行 那我们进入我们另外一个话题这个其实可能是一个我们最近大家可能会见到很多频率很高的一些词比如说躺平 搞钱 求稳 卷 创新然后对于这个问题我觉得三位嘉宾你们会会会会做一些什么样的选择呢然后你们
包括你们为什么会这么选的原因是什么对 要不我们还是先请那个这个问题我们要不请理事长先回答一下吧那不好意思我先来这个我这人啊 我不管你是什么行业的如果你是程序员也是搞钱如果你是比如说做UI的做UX的我认为都应该在尽量用
發揮你最大的技術最大的能力在你經歷最旺盛的時候能搞錢就搞錢為什麼呢很多人其實生了孩子以後不好結婚以後生活狀態就會發生變化包括公司對他們的態度會發生變化我跟咱們國內的程序員在交流的時候比如說有很多人到日本來工作交流的時候我發現什麼這幫人他們可能被公司的社長洗腦可能會被公司的領導洗腦就說你要對公司有忠誠度
你现在这个工资其实不能给你涨了因为为什么不能给你涨是因为别人会眼红所以怕别人受影响不能给你涨工资我觉得这都是在放屁我当过程序员我现在也当社长我不给员工谈中程度没有用特别是现在的90后、90后大家就是搞钱如果他不给你这个工资只能说明一个问题两个问题吧比如说他公司就是有问题或者是你自己有问题公司有问题换公司自己有问题就不断的在去他去补漏
从别人身上吸收你看那些比你工资高的人他有还没有优点他有哪一些就是公司离不开他的地方就是搞钱比如说我认识的这个微博上有很多这个大微呀他们为什么明明已经有很高薪的工作了年薪百万肯定是有了比如说北大清华毕业了我认识清华的比较多那他们为什么还要出书他们还要去出25块钱一本书呢不就是为了搞钱吗你以为人出书真的是说给大家
就这么好心的分享很多很多的知识可能50%是这样但是50%他的动力是挣钱给他的孩子带来更好的未来给他的家人带来更多的幸福所以程序人找工作找公司不是为了中程度你别给我谈什么创新这个先以搞钱为主在你有能力的时候特别是30岁35岁之前在国内先把钱搞到手挣最多的钱
过最爽的日子 等你生孩子以后 等你结婚以后真的就变了 变天了就好的 我的分享就这些 谢谢李社长他其实就分享了一个非常 我怎么讲就是非常制服的一个观点就是很制服 就是这个东西好像是 你不管是什么行业好像都是一个很普遍的主题
因为我们不管是我是做工作还是说自己做那目的都是这样的我们既然会讲一句话经济基础决定上层建筑那如果你在没有把这个经济就这个钱搞定的情况下其实再往上去做一些别的事情可能都是空谈都是空中楼隔但可能对于这个问题我还特别好奇范老师因为范老师可能确实一个非常我觉得还是说在就是非常技术的一个一个嘉宾吧那我想范老师就在你这个角度来说比如说尤其你就是
呃怎么说就是在ai这个方向上嘛我觉得应该是一个比较创新的领域那你对这些东西你会怎么去选啊对呃对我觉得是要考前这个是一个基础嘛就是有以前有一种说法叫做面线面线工资变成呃不知道大家听说过没有就是以前有一个提法叫面线工资变成嘛但是呃我觉得它是一个一个重要的方面而且是一个很重要的方面比如说我们
但是在這個基礎之上的話你還是可以就是說那個我們前面提到的說你要做的方向那方向很重要那我覺得做的方向的話我就說你比如說你可以選擇那個比較創新的新的方向去做這個有的時候不是為了說也不是也不單單說公司中程或者新的這些也不是就是說從個人選擇的角度來說你這幾年工作就是工作無論是你
做哪个方面的事情那同样的是工作的话那你可以在每一次可以选择的时候选择就是相对来说比较下一代的技术呃比如说我自己做的呃及时那个调整的方向都是呃都是就是就是每一次都是去做那个就是相对来说呃他也可能是下一代平台技术平台技术的方向啊那呃就我们前面也提到就说那个就说关于就说呃
是技術重要呢還是就是說跟人溝通啊或者就是那個去分享啊演講啊或者說服人重要其實都是重要的只是他在不同層面呢就是就是他實際上就是說我剛才提到就是說呃有很多方很多方向他可以就是可以產生嗯就看產生方大效應一種是叫技術就往往一個新技術他最早期的時候他是技術決定做人的
比如說那個任何一個平台技術就是一棟互聯網幹出來的時候那技術是重要的那區科鏈幹出來的時候也是那個程序技術是那個主導作用的然後在往前的話就是那個互聯網早期的話也是技術企圖導作用但是技術的話它在找在一個新方向早期的時候它取決定性作用但是在往下的話可能會是產品取決定作用因為現在說這個技術已經成熟了相對成熟的情況下那這個時候就是
大家就比拼产品吧对吧那那商品如果又那个他也有他的魂力机嘛过了他的魂力机的话那可能会出现机魂爆魂的产品他占绝对主导地位比如说先微信啊都都应啊这些都是属于那个啊占主导地位的或者微博就是他们在这微博早期的时候先在微博之间是推特嘛那但是在往下的话就是产品也不起决定作业了在往下可能会变成呃应云应云起决定作业就是
所以就是那这个时候你在不同阶段那他可能重要的那个就是说你的那个就是你你的你的能力的编辑价值可能是不同的所以就是在不同阶段你的他你需要发展的那个能力可能是不不一样的嘛对吧那其实我前面就提到说那个我在编工作的时候我们我也编存那个理解那个行业的规律或者就是技术的规律那去有很多规律他实际上包含了刚才李社长提到的那几点
就是一個健康的成長的程序員他應該包含所技術的方面那在往往上做的話他應該理解說呃如何跟人溝通和交流那如何在同隊內那個溝通和交流如何是你的leader那個去溝通的交流那甚至在往外的話比如說你能不能出去跟人去溝通去交流那比如說呃呃甚至有些程序員他很他確實會受苦比如說你讓他上台做個演講或者是分享的話他可能也會很呃
他可能会比较害羞但是就是说我从我的角度来说就是说程序员的话在不同阶段的话都应该去锻炼自己不擅长的能力你应该尽可能发挥你擅长的能力但是同时你可以去把不是那么擅长的方向去通过锻炼的话来改来来获得那个提升是吧OK所以就是我是觉得说在搞钱的技术上面的话你同时方向上面尽可能选择就是比较新的方向
然后你这个一个时间中你要做的事情那你就尽量就是做的做的就是你自己觉得很牛逼反正就是说那个发了时间就那另外就是说我自己刚好是我出来工作的时候我已经是那个我就是就那就是已经结婚生者了所以就是所以我是觉得说那个呃就是
每一个人看的角度都是一个侧面,但是这个世界上总是会有不同类型的人,从那来说长期来看的话,就是说你给自己设定一个相对比较高的有追求的方向的话是不会有什么大的问题的。
所以像我理解范老师这边其实还是比较倾向于创新这个方向上去对不对我觉得其实范老师在这个问题里面我觉得分享一个很有意思的观点就是我觉得我是觉得受益满大就是要去抓住这个行业的一个设计这个行业的发展规律对吧是的就是比如说现在流行的WeberSummer他实际上还是在很早期的技术去决定主导作业的阶段但是当然他的那个
那么产品也跌了很快但是目前还是在摸索期嘛一般来说一个新技术在就是摸索期的话技术人有可能就是在里面获得一个巨大的魂里说嗯这个技术平台是有技术的那个
对对对我理解其实就是抓住行业的发展规律可能确实在这个整个发展规律里面比如说在早期是比较尊重技术的在网中间一点可能是产品在后面是运营那作为技术同学的话那肯定是你要抓住一个技术可能在比较前期的一个时候去投入里面这样的话你可能的话更少的经济或者更多的回报我是不可以这么理解就无论是搞钱藏兵还是你都是一个成本收益的一个视角对吧那其实货金派也就是说一个就是说
我們不需要說創新是一個道德或者說那個就是驅動而是一個你經過評估之後理性角度覺得說創新確實也是一個不錯的方向然後它有很長的就是它的天花板很高就是如果你的方向比較高的話那你自己確實也樂愛變成和技術的話那你也可以選擇這個方向走就是它不是唯一的方向但是它是一個方向
对我理解其实范小和想这个观点就是一个RI的问题我如果能躺平搞到钱是最好的可以可以好的好那我们看一下那个洪敏老师这边有没有什么想要补充的就是因为躺平这个话题其实在这一两年这个年轻人的这个圈子里面特别流行啊
我們首先來看這個躺平的概念其實如果說是我們長官表面理解那種昏日子的那種躺平其實我是比較反對的就是我是覺得說每個人不管你在什麼階段不管你多麼的富有或者說是貧窮是吧你都有自己應該去要學習或者要進步的空間我在微博上寫了一個叫話題叫做企業加二代這一個系列的一個短的評論然後我在裡面就
也要深度研究或者说是分析了一些大佬的孩子比如说这个华为任正非的这个儿女们吧还有这个娃哈哈创始人宗亲后的女儿宗福利还有这个农夫三权的这个创始人钟闪闪的儿子钟树子是吧钟闪闪更是这两年成为首富了然后还有这个海兰之家的这个创始人周健平的儿子周立晨其实这些人差不多都是30来岁
更年輕的像任正肥的小女兒姚安娜更是這個20多歲那麼就這些人首先他們都有一個統一的標準就是他們可能都不缺錢對吧但是呢就是我們會看到說他們還是非常的勤奮的他們都還是在這個他們父親的基礎上然後不斷地去探索這個他們這個領域的新技術也好啊新或者新零售或者是新的一些商業模式對這是就是說這個
关于不管你多富有其实都是需要再去发展寻找自己的这个进步空间另外我觉得就是我们还要从另一个视角去看待坦平就是我觉得坦平可以分两个概念吧一个就是说真的像我前面说的就是婚日子或者说红横恶恶漫无目的地去过每一天甚至是总是在向下比较还有一种就是我们叫它叫默默耕耘就说并不是那么的浩高物眼
如果是从这个表面意思来理解其实我们可以看两个人是吧比如说我们两个比较成功的影视人物一个是那个阿干症状里面的阿干或者说是那个士兵突击里面的许三多其实他们两个呢都是还某种程度上还是挺符合这个躺平的概念的是吧他们就不那么的着急是吧不很少去攀比然后看着也没有什么太大的理想和这个人生的目标是吧还有他特别是许三多和成才相比那我完全是一个躺平的人了
但是即便是在這個他們這兩個人就是在一個共同特點就是說在一個非常極異不是叫非常普通的叫極其普通的一個或者極其頻繁的崗位上他們都能默默誤文然後做到極致我覺得就是因為他們的專注而不耗高務遠就是著眼當下力足當下結果反而取得了非常不錯的這個成就
大的成就那其实我相信在我们现在很多这个年轻人群中他们说自己要躺平其实不是真的说是放弃了自己的人生而是说不着急啊因为首先他可能说不是像我们80后内70后那一代是吧就是说年轻的时候还吃不饱饭甚至说是就是不是吃不饱而是说是吃的不那么好但是现在就是说这个如果是00后或者年轻人也好就是他们
应该是父母都给他们一些财产或者说给他们一些房产给他们一些知识的灌输他们其实某种程度上是一个物质精神都没蛮充分的所以他们有这个基础条件不着急是吧我才二多岁我宁愿在这个三十多岁我不着急去赚一套房子或者赚个什么我不着急有因为我有房子是吧这是一个很好的物质基础所以我是相信说有很多人一个是他不是真正的躺平而一个是如果是躺那种
婚日子式的躺平其实我是不太认可的还是希望说去站在自己的这个角度和现状上去寻找自己的这个空间谢谢好的好的谢谢红明老师同学啊然后对于后续的一个发展大家有什么建议呢对吧就是我们这样讲有的可能是主动自己想想走嘛然后还有一些是被毕业的同学那后续发展应该怎么样去继续走这样的一个职业生涯之路那我们还是把时间先交给李社长
李珊这边先分享一下好我先来对于主动被毕业的同学主动按的被毕业的同学后期的发展有什么建议啊首先这被毕业啊或者是主动离职肯定大家都有两种情况比如说第一种被毕业的话嗯比较担心的应该就是公司吧比如说最近国内的热钱的确是少了很多包括我在日本这边我也知道就是撤资了外资都撤资了
所以導致咱們包括京東多破很多的大企業可能財源比率甚多了30%到35%這種大環境互聯網行動是我們無法改變的如果你遇到這種情況了這應該不是你自身的問題不是你自身的問題的話你無力改變它那你就怎麼說換一條出路比如說我認識的國內一個互聯網大廠雷朋友他原來在那拿的是很高的年薪但是某一些原因他被人替代了被人替代以後
他选择了一条复国的道路去了澳大利亚当然前提是他的英文也很好然后他去澳大利亚他有国内的一个大厂背景有酒吧玩了毕业背景一面市就面世上了然后他先去到澳大利亚后来全家移民到澳大利亚然后拿到了比国内还要勾的这个叫什么他们那边叫offer 信仇待遇
甚至在澳大利亚过上了这个我非常非常羡慕的日子还有很多的同学呢后来避免这个为了避免996为了避免卷跑到了新西兰跑到了新加坡甚至有一些这个喜欢日本东班同学来到了日本那出路有很多不是说只在国内才能活下去对吧这个特别是程语言你学的这个开发语言你去这个
不用说地球上了你去火星加来火星难道不需要软件开发吗肯定也需要吧哪都能用这个主动毕业的同学这个发展的建议吧我觉得怎么说呢你肯定是有想法你没想法你干嘛要提离职呢我们之前朋友之间交流是有一种之外种思想就是尽量的搞钱搞到财务自由财务自由以后你就跟公司白白一脚把公司拆了那这叫主动
要主动离职其他的还有什么想听的发展建议大家可以这个在发账目我觉得发展来说吧首先大家要想的是怎么去搞钱把财务尽量自由化或者说是你有一个比较稳定比较好的保障吧因为毕竟很多人不知道什么时候自己就不能挣钱了因为朋友他
本来挺好的然后突然有一天就发现癌症了发现癌症了你公司也不能给你提供什么保障你说你到时候需要钱你怎么整啊有的时候真的是很无奈就是人渐渐康康的挣钱的时候什么都行一旦有病了也真的是天都要塌了那老朋友不挣钱孩子也不挣钱家里还有老人要养成绪员奋斗这么多年后不是你发起高年薪突然有一天对癌症了都是真实情况啊你们
可能现在还没到那个地步吧所以这个发展建议就是能对财务有把控的时候大家就是对财务尽量的去追求一下明白所以我觉得理上这个其实出于一个风险控制吧我就感觉其实聊下来我觉得理上就是那种属于风险控制特别控制意识特别强的人
但你或者5年以后包括个人的发展融线包括我跟公司这么在谈这个你以后走什么技术路线你为什么要这个呀你为什么现在要努力我跟他们去讲一些比较现实的一些例子因为大厂又怎么了小厂又怎么了城市园这个行业有一些很多就加班扎到那一头就栽过去了这个不可避免这种事情因为你毕竟这个每个人的身体透支啊不断的透支不断的熬夜肯定都是我当时就是什么996过来我深有体会都是有一定的
承受限度的那有些人家家的官夸那笔鞋就留下来我们当时在国内多吓人所以一定有这个风险控制意识的为将来打算即便是你没有了的话你也有为你的家人做打算明白然后那个那范老师这边呢有没有对我同意就是对我同意先先先说一点就是
程序無論是在哪個還是要注意作息就是無論你的工作環境是怎樣的就是個人要控制住自己那個作息的情況我確實也有朋友他們有的時候工作很緊張就是可能連續連好幾週因為他吃個飯都沒困那一般遇到這種情況下我會我之前我有那個之前有一個流行的就是就是世界衛生組織發的一個就是說如何爛自己就是控制
遇到這種情況下如何調整自己的一些小冊子那個其實挺好的就是如果你有朋友或者是你自己是在一種很緊張的狀態下連你的朋友因為你吃個飯的時間都沒有那你肯定是要調整一下無論是什麼原因都得調整一下就是這點先說一下然後第二個就是說那個主動或者被動被畢業的那我說一下就是被
就是有一种情况就是比如说你确实是工作中那可能技效比较差那可能会被毕业了嘛那这种情况下的话那当然就是你如果你有更好的机会那肯定也挺好的也没什么问题那但是我从长期来看就是说如果你发生过这种情况那多多少少说明说你在工作中有些东西没做好就是那这有可能有几种原因那比如像李社长说的一种说
OK那你可能覺得說我確實就是不是擅長這個在這個上面你沒能把自己的能力徹底發揮出來那你可以另行踏入那也沒有問題但是如果你還想繼續做的話那我的建議就是就是還是要把自己那個基礎打擾就是你要
嗯去还是要学习嘛就是有就是我们很多有的人他就学校毕业在学校里面的时候花时间学习然后出去工作的话他事实上他是停止了他的那个就学习新新的那个技术啊方向或者就内容的他停止了但是IT技术他就发展很快了有的时候不是说原理性的东西在变我是很多空甲技术啊然后工具量啊他一直在变然后这些东西也当然也不是最本质的那肯定现在比如说现在java
做厚多呢他先swimboot之類的那可能他技術幾年都不會有什麼大的變化但是那為什麼有的人做得好有的人做得不好那肯定也是有關係的那有幾種有你們一種是我個人是比較反對9966但是但是我是覺得說如果他不是一個非常緊湊非常非常那個就是壓力很大的情況下的工作狀態下那作為一個技術的話你如果就是連續的比如說你連續好幾個基督那個技巧都是C或者
那可能是有原因的可能你真的就是在工作態度啊跟方法方式上面是有問題的那這方面的話是可以調可以就是說呃如果你要找到他到底是哪個方面的原因嗎如果是技術如果是能力的問題你就可以去那個去學習和補除如果是溝通的問題比如一個人他不是能力不行他缺乏就是剛才黎社長說的他缺乏就是去理解這個項目或者這個團隊他的目標
共同的目標是什麼嘛那他總是做不到點算或就是說那個交付的比如說一個任務下去他可能應該分解成幾個具體的小步驟去拆分去交付那他當時他有的人他不短的如何拆分他可能過了一個月他還在做他事實上在做但是他不能夠就是把中間過程交付出去那別人一直就不知道他到底啥狀態一直在主宰就實際拆下來我覺得說拋開那些不合理的那個工作狀態那我們大家其實大家都都是
我覺得說確實不合理的話那他應該是反對的但是如果是在一個合理範圍內的那你其實還是要去找到真正的問題所在就是去補足或者去調整或者去學習就是人一定要那個誠實的面對自己那個到底是哪方面那個缺的那然後去補足他嘛那我前面說了就是主動還是被動那都是只是中間的一個過程過了幾年之後很快他就過去了
其实无论它是多么惨的但是要往前看因为我还想在这个方向往下做的话那你就要去那个找到原因然后就是补出自己再往前走好的好的行然后呢我们就最后再问一下洪敏朗是这边吧就关于这个有没有一些对就是我我自己就是说
因為本身前面講到說我自己的職業經歷並不多然後更多的是和朋友的瞭解就是說關注到說有關這個離職的問題首先就是你主動畢業的同學呢就是我首先不是特別建議裸詞就是盡量就是說旗旅找馬在這個無縫的前接然後同時呢我是也結合自己的那種經驗我非常
建議大家要重視找工作這段時間的一個經歷因為就是你求職的這段時間比如說是每天在面試或者經常在面試就是說可能是你整個職業生涯中了解這個行業開吐自己的事業最佳的一個時間窗口因為我們知道每個公司出來做面試官的那個人他可能是這個公司比較核心的而且是能力非常強的一個中高層管理者
甚至是一把手而且另外就说一个公司它能稳定的运转说明这个公司还是有非常独特的然后过人的一个理念也好价值观也好是吧那就是说你在和这样一个公司里面的一个高层中高层非常优秀的中高层聊个几十分钟或者十几分钟我觉得一定会让你受益飞浅的就是你可能和他的一个交流中你已经
了解整个行业中现在这种技术比较需要现在整个行业中我的水平处在什么一个段位我的需求是怎么样的可能很快就能了解了而且还会开拓了说比如你面试了十家公司可能会了解十种不同的
相对不同的发展模式运营理念我觉得即便是说你面试失败了你可能下次你就会知道说我面试的失败源在哪里可能对方介意的是我的口才也好或者是我的开发能力也好或者说我的一个其他一个地方或者我前段的工作时间太短了在整个面试过程中你会有一种一日千里的感觉就是我当时面试的时候就会有这种感觉
但是你一旦树植了一家公司以后呢你的这个顾取心知识的这个机会就少多了所以说大家一定要重视这个找工作的这个这个过程说不要怕很多人说我面试了10家还没找的工作我是不是不行啊我是不是能力太差大家都不需要我其实我觉得这面试这个10个10家的这个过程其实是非常宝贵的你不要再
怕再面致10家我觉得不用怕的不需要用面称多少产生一种新回忆能自我否定甚至是非常焦虑的一种状态这是针对主动毕业的一个同学但是如果被毕业同学其实我觉得比较关键就是说你要在意的是自己的各种权益比如说这个赔偿公司该给的赔偿报仇这个部分我给你一下可以稍后聊因为我们有这个话题可以稍后聊一下好的
谢谢刚好就是这个话题对然后要不还是那个刚好洪敏老师来讲一下对他就是权益就关于被毕业权益的问题对
如果我就是说是现在就是说因为现在就是比较多的你像我看前两天比较火的时候看到京东啊或者说一横着的友在呀他们的那个毕业场面是吧就是说不小心被暴露出来了一整框一整框的工牌放在那里啊是挺吓人的所以就当时那个照片就非常火啊如果是被动毕业的话其实我觉得首先就是
維護自己的合法權益其中就是賠償另外就是說我覺得要有兩個點要平衡好就是說你自己的權益和老東家的關係這兩個點你要做好平衡這一點其實是蠻關鍵的因為就是說這些老同事或老東家老同事他對你未來的職業生涯其實是可能會有一點點影響甚至有時候這個影響是很關鍵的比如說你未來的公司在招聘你的時候會做一個不僅調查這個時候如果
你走的时候直接跟领导拍桌子或者是出言不讯了是吧甚至直接把人都删了是吧那这个人家可能就最后一句他表现一般是吧那可能就是新的老板可能就不想要你了是吧有这种感觉可能他会影响你的职业生涯就是还有就是就是因为你毕竟你在这家公司工作了是吧你的这个比如工作两年是吧那你宝贵的生命中的两年
是吧?那么每天算12小时吧你是花费的这家公司啊说其实还是有必要去珍惜自己过去的这两年的这个生命啊然后还是比如说你在这两家这两家公司工作这个经理本身就是一个很大的财富啊很大的一个资源说未来你你到到别的公司去说啊我在A公司B公司工作过那
他可能会对你这是你的一个加分甚至是减分的一个印象吧还是要珍惜这个工作经历就是为了另外了就是说未来的老板也会看嘛就是因为有一次面试我就经历过这样一个问题就是这就是宿命题你上一家公司为什么会离职啊有很多人就会说这个我参加公司老板这不行那不行我们
同事不行这不行那不行公司发展不行说了一堆不行那其实这个时候其实就是呃这我觉得这不是面试官喜欢听到的回答啊就是未来老板其实他会看你你和之前老东家的关系是吧如果都是非常如果每家每个老东家都很僵他其实可能不是公司的问题未来的老板会认为是你个人的问题如果是啊对这这就一个这个问题我希望大家注意一下就备毕业以后的一个问题对嗯
这个是一个比较现实的问题,确实。然后那个理事长这边呢?哦,我这边对国内的这个其实我不是太了解,国内的这些权益什么的,你能不能说一下日本这边的几个例子吧?你比如说日本这边它是有一个正式联、七月事联和白银事联之分的,如果你是这个七月事联或者是正式联的话,它是无论如何都是永久雇佣池,这个叫无期间雇佣池,就是不能
不亦辞退你的除非是给你一定的补偿金比如说半年的工资之类之类的这样对双方有好协商下才可以被所谓的所被毕业被裁员那其他的来说呢有些公司为了避免这个赔偿金的发生他会把这些人弄到什么仓库去干活或者给他一些算不好的环境这些在日本电视剧和新闻里也都出现过
那实际上如果真的发生的话吧大部分还是保护这个个人劳动者权益的因为日本它毕竟是一个讲法的社会它有这个劳动监督署啊个人比如说拿再举一个例子日本这个契源合同吧如果这个企业活动上很多东西都写明了的话吧那你这个条款是正常条款或者是不正常条款都是保证个人的权益的就是你拿这个去中财去劳动中财打官司在日本个人一定会赢了公司
就基本上是這樣除非你公司使一些什麼印招之類的我再說一個這個舉個例子就夫妻本是同理鳥大案零頭各自飛就像兩個夫妻在平時生活中甜甜蜜蜜但一旦離婚了以後大家關注的都是怎麼分財產怎麼分錢那就是這個像你跟公司的關係一樣那既然要離婚了大家把錢談清楚我覺得就可以了沒必要弄的什麼面子上過不去或者是有什麼
彼此有像不好的印象就是该走的时候弄快快的走拿到你该拿的东西白白的领外就该找新的出路就ok了说不定这个时候是你这个职业生涯的一个转折我觉得答案就像我跟范老师之前经常说这个危机变成转机就可以了勇敢的跟过去说白白寻找新的道路说不定将来的发展会更好我觉得这个你身上其实你就是一个典范嘛对吧
因为我没法改变那些无法改变的事情所以就主演未来想一想我现在能改变能做出什么改变
得到什麼更好的利益從這個世界中吸取教訓我將來要往什麼更好的路上去發展在冷靜的思考分析一下我是比較善於這個綜合分析的就主要想將來的事情因為過去的事情已經過去了你無力改變這個公司財源的局面你無力改變這個大環境那你就為將來著想以後避免出現同樣的事情就避免在同一個坑裡掉到兩次OK關於這個問題那個范老師還有什麼要補充的嗎
對我同意就是如果是發生了那就是把什麼的權益那個理清楚嘛談好就是理性的談好就是不要就是該是你的權益你就維護你的權益然後跟一般公司國內目前這塊一般還是比較一般除非是一些很一些小公司可能會就不健全大部分來說還是比較正常的就是你就好好跟人事談然後好好跟你的上級去談嘛
明確的就明確的把事情談清楚然後談完了之後呢有明確的結論之後呢那你自己決定要怎麼決定下來然後把該所謂的事情做好就我覺得如果真發生的話呢就是還是一樣就是哪個結論都把那個結論該做的事情做好然後你的權益的話一般現在來說都是比較合規的就是去跟人事啊或者去談好
那一般來說也是需要跟自己利得去溝通好一下就是了就明確的話但是我不大建議就是說在這個過程中就是猶豫不決就是說又又如果你做好決定確定要走那裡就那裡就決定嘛那就如果是被被動的話也是一樣被動的話那他你不能改變結果了那你也好好談就是談好權益然後做好該該做的作為
就這樣因為其實關注他只是你人生中的一戰我明白對其實我們問這個問題講的這個哪些權益其實也不是說講的其實是當下的一個權益因為我們其實如果要講當下權益肯定也不會說是我們可能是請專業的律師什麼之類的講這個東西我們其實講這個問題就是因為畢業嘛他可能可能大家以後他是一個結束但其實我覺得他不是一個結束他是另外一個開始嘛
他这个权益其实就涉及到当下的权益和一个更长远的一个权益所以我理解我们今天的三位嘉宾包括红铭老师包括李社长以及范老师他们都在讲一个点就是希望大家在维护当前正常权益的情况下也要好好想一想自己为了用你的职业生涯是很长的你要想想你为了职业生涯的这个权益你怎么去把它长期的去维护好所以我觉得他们分享的这个观点怎么说呢非常普世而且也非常有价值就希望大家都能
就是在对直播线同学有一些帮助好的那到今天到这里的话呢还有这个问题啊对这个问题就是我们被逼这是从时代发展来看就因为今天我们其实在整个过程带可以讲到一个包括范朗谁提到关于这个时代发展的一个点那从这个讲来有没有有机可询呢就是我们怎么样去尽量去避免这样一个东西就是我们从社会发展的角度来看一下这个事情首先那个
红铭老师来吧因为你确实可能一直在观察整个互联网对科技互联网就是我觉得这个我最近有个观察就是说是从公司毕业这件事就是观察到说就是可能很多人也看到说00后出来整顿职场各种各样就是搞小的段子是吧比如说领导说在群里说清明节我们不休息了是吧然后
林林後的員工就會回覆 怎麼了?老闆你家沒有祖墳嗎?就是就會有這樣很神的對這個領導的一些這個截圖還在網上流傳 特別有意思但是其實我看到說這個新的年輕人他的一個職場人對於一個細節就是說他們對社保和供給金去關注程度是非常之高的他們把這個社保供給金當成了說自己非常重要的壓箱底的將來一定會用到的一筆錢
这和我们当年,就一零年左右进入职场的时候,那个时候是完全不一样的。我们那会儿一般几十人,甚至上百人的公司,在这个公司里面对攻击基因一个是不怎么懂。
然后老板也会忽悠我们说你首先你现在很年轻才二来岁然后你这公斤设保公斤金可能也是被养了保险什么的到退休以后才能用得着那你时间还很遥远现在没啥用所以说我按照最低的标准给你交公斤金比如说你本来该交一千的只给我交三百就可以了然后甚至有的公司就不交
然后就是作为回报领导说我给你多发100块钱200块钱工资是吧你看这是眼前的钱多好那很多时候有很多老板会通过这个个人账户给我们发工资然后其实他说就是这样可以避免我们员工交个人所得税是吧同时公司这个也逃了很多税是吧然后那从这种情况来讲就是说真的是当时用现在的这个法律标准来判断当时的一些行为的话真的是
非常乱 职场非常乱 但是如今呢就是说这个00后出来整顿职场是吧 就是说我相信那多数的老板他也不敢在各种各样的市场去压榨或者磕扣这些员工了比如说这个像很多年轻的员工说团建团建你出去玩是吧 也得参加班是吧 这挺有意思的然后什么市网供应金更是得老老实实给我交
然后所以说他首先呢就是说这个职场年轻人他们对于工作的这个态度和过去是发生了很大的变化那我们在过去就是说发一个工作总感觉领导都不是比我们有钱的人是吧能力比我们强是自立比我们老的人我们要尊敬他甚至我们要怕他是吧但是现在这个年轻人就是在这个年轻人眼里就是工作就是一份工作是吧不是我生命的全部然后反而是你都得按照法律来
像勞動仲裁、起訴、公司對他們一樣可能都是加上變犯我聽資訊就能加強就說把這些設計完成了但是我看到說相對應的就是說一些年齡比較大的公司管理層他們好像還沒有適應這種轉變所以說看到說很多年輕人對於從公司離開、畢業這件事其實沒有那麼的越來越
不是一件特别可怕的事情了过去一说失业了非常可怕现在重立公司走了肯定还有别的公司可以要我是吧实在不行现在有很多就是说这种年轻人他的一个创业思路非常的多是吧你比如说在小红书上天天分享一下自己的美照也能养一养活自己是吧去直播一下然后出去干个小歌题都是蛮能养活自己的
現在這個就是新一代年輕人首先他們這個物質上相對來講比我們那會安全一些所以他們對未來的這個探索其實是更大膽這是我看到的一個現象謝謝明白OK然後那你現在正在這個話點你現在這邊有什麼想聊一聊的嗎哦說等下我這兒哦好OK了
我觉得从时代发展来看肯定是有即可循的比如说我当年毕业的时候赶上08年几年经济危机所有的公司互联网公司都是裁员那个时候还是一个蓬勃发展的这么一个年代那个危机的时候都裁员何况是现在其实互联网的风口互联网的红利器已经过去了我觉得它肯定会向国外的这个
互聯網環境一樣就漸漸的不會再有獨角獸的產生漸漸的大家都平穩了也不會再有非常牛逼的這個企業產生因為這個首先你目前為止就這幾年來看國內其實沒有出現什麼太厲害的企業了也沒有出現太大型的這種互聯網公司了不管是什麼拼都多還是什麼我覺得這都是找這些沒有找這些比如說阿里他們沒有做過的領域來切入
所以在技术方面创新我觉得应该不会有太大的企业所诞生了在这种背景下以后一旦出现什么效益不好或者是再来经济危机的话肯定还会被裁员那既然我们明白了它有经济危机和互联网红利器已经都过去了这个发展路径它一般都会10年或者是几年这么一个轮替的话那如何归辟呢我觉得这是储备
可能比较重要吧我目前为止认识的两类程序员一类是我们叫二刀流比如说他计会OS开发DQ和安卓开发他不太满足以自己现状他会一直在学新的技术比如他去研究一个自己感兴趣的领域然后又精通自己生存技能吃饭的这么一个开发语言类似于这种甚至现在
有成群也是去抖音啊做一些分享或者是去Bilibili做一些分享包括有很多的大牛成群在YouTube也变得渐渐有名了这都是不错的一个手段你比如说在推特上我认识一些比较有名的这个外国的大牛他们为什么这么在乎自己的名声这么想大力的黑广想变得有名我觉得一旦你在世界上变得有名了那你在中国找工作在外国找工作都不成问题
你如何愿意去分享你如何愿意把你的技术比如说说成人的话或者让大家都能来得到成长就这种能说把你的知识变成力量变成大家都喜欢去学习的东西去分享很多真实的东西还是挺重要的不光是说你自己学好的技术什么什么就可以了从这些方面来考虑吧就是变得有名技术储备
包括将来的其他的知识的路线什么的我认为红明老师和那个理事长其实分享了两个完全不同的视角红明老师其实从他从现在的一些社会热点的东西来看到比如说现在的一个年轻人针对于这个对于这种雇佣关系的一个思路的变化那可能对于这个被毕业的这个东西那对于这个结果来说可能
它的预测就是说后期可能对于这些年前不有那么大影响而李社长呢其实是分享了我们目前整个互联网时代嘛就是目前这个互联网移动互联网时代的一个发展的一个时代它有一些变化比如说已经到了一个就红利系已经过了嘛那它可能确实会有一些比较就是确实会它是在有一个这样的一个点就是在往下走
那其实我觉得可能还会有一些就参与讲到一些可以去做一些新的技术的尝试或者说做一些新的方向的探索那这个点其实我觉得应该是范老师这边先应该是等于是还是在一个新的怎么说的在一个新的赛道上一个比较比较火的赛道上那其实我想听一下范老师这边的一个想法对好的其实以前有本书已经到现在都还挺好的时候就是叫烂槽之巅我老大家应该多看过就是那本书其实
呃他就是就是我们你这边写的说那个从时代的发展来看有计可循吗那肯定是有人那其实大家呃烂潮时间那边数就挺好了他讲了很多就是IT企业他在不同阶段那个他为什么就在不同阶段他如何发展起来的然后他有些又是如何衰落的然后有些又是在转型过程中如何那个改变了吗那现在所以就是说我们如果你以前有的时候了解未来最好的方式之一是呃
去看過去發生的事情那就是你要需要了解那些歷史上曾經揮霍的那些公司他們是怎麼起來的那他都是有原因的嘛然後所以就是說我的一個觀點之一就是說有的人成全他趕上時候然後他被畢業那他也有可能原因是他自身學習能力不足他可能就是那個平常缺乏就是對於一些
那个潮流的敏感度那他因为如果他对潮流是有敏感度的话或者说那他可能就是就先很会做风险控制的你理社长就是你如果预估到说这个方向是有风险的那你应该提前准备吧无论是从哪种角度搞成或者就是那个提补补先自己自身知识或者就是那个但是
為什麼有的人他就能夠持續的在長期的過程中可以做到有的人他就不行了那我覺得一個很重要的東西叫做就是你得意識到你能感知到這些東西的話是因為你的知識儲備決定了你能感知到或者你能夠判斷到這個潮流跟方向或者是那個那怎樣那個提升自己的感知度呢一個很重要的東西就是平常是有機類的那其實那個一種古老的方式就是閱讀書籍就是譬如說我自己的話
到目前还能保持每年大概又读十分左右数嘛那你可以有一些比例的缓和那比如说那个有些是那个呃有些是像我自己一个人的话有些是属于社科类的有些是属于那个技术书籍然后有些是属于那个就是呃就长明啊或者心理学或者其他各方面的嘛你可以一定的配例嘛但是你不能就说但确实有很多人他工作几年之后他已经彻底不看数了
那你知道在今天这个时代看直播是一种分子啊那就是他很随偏化那如果你看那个抖音机面上我也会很随偏化的方式他能获取一些那个知识那个一铃半招但是系统性的知识还是苏继是那个最最有最有效的就是了有的时候就是很多东西他不是立刻能够帮助到你但是如果你有了这些那个知识储备的话他有一个东西就是你做判断上大底不会太差
這是一個觀點,就是你要從歷史上面去看時代發展的規矩,它是一種修煉內觀的方式,另外一種判斷未來的方式就是去創造未來,這說起來比較大,怎樣去創造未來的程序員最核心的工作就是創造。
比如說我是計算數學博士數學我一出來工作就不斷地思考數學跟計算計算有什麼區別數學它最關鍵的是官司就是它能夠把官司來表徵這個世界它把官司寫下來但官司不需要跑它不需要可以運行那寫程序你寫個Hello World的話有個bug它就跑不了那誰就是程序做IDG
就是这一块,你就是一个创造性的工作,那你就是创造性的工作的话,反正你写真正插盖带嘛,你也是在写,写某个引擎技术嘛,你如果写一把引擎或者写一个那个就是,呃,去过了引擎或者写一个就是那个就是,嗯,分布式系统引擎啊,或者是也都是也都是写嘛。
那其实并不是说你一定要做底层就是中间层的话你要是对业务理解很深刻的话你也可以针对业务场景去建模那你也可以做出那个真正解决你的凝率问题的那个技术和场面我们刚才提了很多东西就是说程序员还可以扩展就是那些轮的技能对不对但是作为一个程序员的安家立命的一个核心还是你的技术能力
那所以我是觉得说就是选择从事选择那个那些那个未来五到十年它还是一个喷波发展的一个技术方向然后在这些方向上面去做我基本上不要说毕业了我基本上找工作我都是很少的我到目前为止就换了那个理论上只换了一次工作那我都是自己主动那个选择的那我就是基本上都是
就是我自己決定了我要做什麼方向然後我要投入時間在哪裡那我要跟什麼樣的人去合作去跟他們去那個學習技術學習產品學習運營對吧那以前我聽到很早以前就聽到學到的地方就是你如果想要獲得進步你要懂得跟高手去交過招和交流就是你得跟一流的人去學習那個和交流那他們就是在每一個階段其實事實上你在每一個階段你都是由
你只能看到你这个接动认知范围内的事情但是其实我们知道就是那个跳出这个接动你做的事情的范围之内还是有很多东西我们都是没有那么精通和掌握的所以就是第二个观点就是说决定自己未来不是等到未来发生的时候你在潮流来的时候你才规定而是在此之前的话五年十年你可能都已经就决定了这个你都已经你自己已经决定了你这个方向你就是这么走的那个到
是把命運掌握在自己的手裡對 OK那其實這兩個都是從個人角度來說我覺得還是比較比較被動的其實總的來說我一直覺得還是要足夠一點就是你給自己設定一個高的目標嘛有一句話說你如果先考100分的話可能能拿到90分嘛那如果你先考60分那可能就是不及格就是這樣的嗯嗯100好的OK謝謝范老師
那到这里的话我觉得今天其实说实话可能我们也有很多观点的一些分享和碰撞因为确实我们能看出来就是这个因为这位三位嘉宾都是来自不同的背景所以他们其实针对一些问题可能会有一些从自己角度的理解当然其实还有很多就大家来说哎觉得这个点大家其实会有一些共同的想法因为我其实在过程中无数听到应该好几次听到饭是说哎还是很同意理事长的一些观点同意侯明朗是一些观点
我觉得可能就是我们今天做这场活动主要就是说希望请到不同背景的这种大咖来分享一下他们对于一些同样的问题的看法我觉得今天的还说从我自己的角度来说我觉得是非常有收获的我相信直播间的同学也会有收获OK 然后其实如果没有看完完整直播同学没关系因为我们后续会把所有的录播都整体出来然后还是会发到我们同样的B站的账号上面